Trascrizione: Claudia Di Lorenzo
Revisore: Federico MINELLE
Questa è una storia vera.
Sono stato invitato qualche tempo fa
a partecipare ad un caffè letterario
sulle Dolomiti.
Un chirurgo invita ogni anno
una personalità di un certo settore,
quell'anno si parlava di spazio
e sono stato invitato io.
Quell'anno era un anno elettrizzante,
perché il nostro satellite Mars Express
aveva trovato, con un radar italiano,
acqua su Marte, liquida, salata.
Ora, acqua liquida salata su Marte,
da un punto di vista scientifico,
è una scoperta epocale,
perché significa molto probabilmente
la presenze di vita su Marte.
Alla fine della serata,
io ero ancora circondato da turisti
che volevano sapere
delle nostre nuove missioni,
delle nuove tecnologie,
e sono stato affrontato da una persona
che mi ha chiesto di guardare questa foto.
Voglio leggerla con voi:
penso che sia del tutto superfluo
che io mi soffermi
sulla tragicità dell'immagine in sé.
Voglio leggere però con voi
la frase a corredo.
"L'umanità non ha i soldi
per estrarre l'acqua nelle zone aride.
Però ha i soldi per cercare
l'acqua su Marte.
La domanda è: c'è vita
intelligente sulla Terra?"
Ora questa è una situazione
alla quale chi fa il mio mestiere
viene esposto piuttosto di sovente,
quindi ho deciso di rispondere
e di farlo con la pacatezza
e la metodicità
che la scienza mi ha insegnato
e voglio farlo con voi oggi.
Comincio con la missione,
forse la più iconica,
di tutte le missioni di esplorazioni spaziali:
l'uomo sulla Luna.
Questa missione ci ha detto:
noi possiamo farlo.
Non soltanto: noi possiamo pensarlo.
Noi siamo l'unica specie
di questo pianeta ad aver fatto questo,
ad aver lasciato il nostro pianeta
ed essere andati sul nostro satellite
ed essere ritornati.
L'unica specie.
Ma in più, questa missione
ci ha regalato molto di più.
135.000 brevetti.
135.000 significa nuovi prodotti,
nuove aziende, nuovi posti di lavoro.
Significa progresso economico,
oltre che scientifico,
significa benessere.
Però uno potrebbe ancora obiettare
che non rispondiamo
alla domanda del bambino.
Ma vediamole, queste tecnologie.
Per prima, la TAC.
La TAC veniva utilizzata
per cercare difetti
sulle strutture immateriali
delle navi di "Apollo".
Oggi la TAC la troviamo
in tutti gli ospedali del mondo
per fare diagnosi,
per guidare la chirurgia.
I filtri per l'acqua che utilizzavamo
per depurare l'acqua degli astronauti
oggi li usiamo in tutte le parti del mondo
dove l'acqua è carente
per permettere a quei bambini
di bere da pozzanghere
altamente contaminate
da virus e da batteri,
perché ora le abbiamo
addirittura rese portatili.
Il microprocessore.
Ora, il processore esisteva già.
Chi fa il mio mestiere però sa
che quel che vola nello spazio
deve essere estremamente leggero
ed estremamente piccolo,
quindi il processore
ha dovuto necessariamente
diventare il microprocessore.
Ora, ditemi, oggi, sulla Terra,
una macchina che non abbia
un microprocessore a bordo.
Intendo tutto,
dall'automobile al vostro telefonino,
agli strumenti medici,
agli strumenti per cercare acqua - tutto.
In più, una serie sterminata
di prodotti tecnici:
abbigliamento per il grande freddo
e il grande caldo;
addirittura per le fiamme;
tute ignifughe per pompieri,
senza amianto;
maschere portatili per l'ossigeno;
coperte termiche, oggi
tristemente indossate dai migranti.
Cibo liofilizzato.
Il cibo liofilizzato che ha perso l'acqua
per essere trasportato nello spazio
si può trasportare molto bene adesso
in tutte le parti del mondo
grazie a questa tecnologia.
Questo però avveniva 50 anni fa.
Oggi che cosa facciamo?
Oggi la nostra priorità è la Terra.
Viviamo un periodo di grandi
cambiamenti, su scala globale.
Abbiamo un'opportunità, però:
possiamo osservarli, comprenderli
ed intervenire per cambiarli,
ed è osservandoli dallo spazio.
Ecco allora che abbiamo
una serie di missioni,
le sentinelle dell'Agenzia
Spaziale Europea,
che ci permettono di fare proprio questo.
Primo, possiamo capire
quali sono gli elementi nocivi nell'aria.
Non soltanto, possiamo capire
la quantità di anidride carbonica:
l'anidride carbonica
ha un effetto secondario,
che è aumentare
la temperatura del pianeta,
quindi misuriamo
lo scioglimento dei ghiacci.
Il polo nord ha perso
dieci taglie di ghiaccio.
Come conseguenza, misuriamo
l'innalzamento dell'acqua.
Il 60% della popolazione mondiale
vive entro 100 km dalla costa,
quindi è un dato estremamente importante.
In più, facciamo qualcosa
di ancora di più.
Non soltanto troviamo acqua
per quel bambino,
ma troviamo umidità,
quindi troviamo
potenzialità di trovare acqua
anche dove questo
è estremamente difficile.
In più, proprio perché abbiamo
trovato l'umidità,
possiamo permettere
una migliore agricoltura,
quindi non soltanto diamo
da bere a quel bambino,
ma gli diamo anche da mangiare.
La cosa interessante di questo
è che il radar che oggi
ci permette di trovare acqua
è lo stesso, o meglio
è l'evoluzione della specie -
è un radar ad apertura sintetica -
è l'evoluzione della specie del radar
che ci ha permesso
di trovare l'acqua su Marte.
Nella sua funzione di interferometria,
quello stesso radar ci permette
di misurare movimenti millimetrici
di tutte le costruzioni
che l'uomo ha sulla Terra:
ad esempio la sanità strutturale
delle scuole dei nostri figli,
le dighe, i ponti.
Chi di voi ha un cellulare?
(Risate)
Chi di voi ha Internet, sul cellulare?
Chi di voi ha un GPS, sul cellulare?
Tutte questi, diciamo, servizi
che per voi sono ovvi e scontati
vi vengono forniti dallo spazio,
vi vengono forniti
dall'Agenzia Spaziale Europea.
Ma l'osservazione della Terra dallo spazio
ci ha permesso di fare qualcos'altro:
ci ha permesso di prendere coscienza
di quanto la Terra sia fragile
e sia esposta, ad esempio,
a questa minaccia.
Cinque estinzioni di massa,
tutte e cinque, ed è
l'opinione scientifica più comune,
sono state generate dall'impatto
con un asteroide superiore
al chilometro di diametro.
Noi oggi non potremmo farci niente,
nessuna agenzia spaziale,
al mondo, può farci niente.
Non voglio rovinarvi la domenica,
non vi preoccupate.
L'ESA e la NASA lavorano
proprio a questa missione:
la missione DART ed Hera.
Questo è Didimo, un asteroide
di un chilometro di diametro.
Non vi preoccupate,
non sta venendo verso la Terra,
però è un ottimo oggetto di test.
Vogliamo colpire la sua luna,
e cambiando la velocità della luna,
defletteremo la traiettoria di Didimo
di 6.000 km.
La Terra è a [11 milioni di km].
Didimo non ci colpirà mai.
Noi, con il nostro ingegno,
con la nostra competenza,
ci siamo costruiti
questa possibilità di sopravvivenza:
i dinosauri non ne sono stati capaci,
e infatti si sono estinti.
Però a noi interessa l'uomo
sullo spazio, l'uomo nello spazio,
e se nel '69 l'uomo nello spazio,
nella missione della Luna,
c'è stato per pochi giorni,
oggi noi abbiamo fatto volare 90 equipaggi
su questo oggetto,
la Stazione Spaziale Internazionale.
Li abbiamo resi eterogenei,
quindi uomini e donne,
e gli abbiamo allungato
la permanenza: almeno sei mesi.
Questo ci ha permesso
di scoprire moltissimi aspetti:
prima di tutto, che l'uomo
non è fatto per volare nello spazio.
Abbiamo moltissimi problemi:
abbiamo osteoporosi,
assottigliamento del muscolo,
assottigliamento
del sistema cardiovascolare,
problemi con le radiazioni.
Ma queste missioni ci hanno permesso
non soltanto di sapere questo,
ma ci hanno permesso
di sviluppare medicine
per curare proprio questi aspetti,
e queste stesse medicine
ce le ritroviamo poi sulla Terra.
Ma la Stazione è stata qualcosa di più:
è stata un esperimento politico.
È stata realizzata da cinque paesi:
Europa, Stati Uniti, Russia,
Canada e Giappone.
E ci ha dimostrato che lo spazio
è una missione talmente alta
che anche quei paesi che a quel tempo
non andavano d'accordo sulla Terra
si sono messi d'accordo,
hanno fatto la pace
per realizzare una missione del genere.
Quindi, se volete,
il problema dell'acqua e del cibo
è prima di tutto un problema tecnico:
Bisogna trovarla, bisogna estrarla.
Ma poi è un problema di distribuzione.
Niente come la missione spaziale
aiuta i rapporti internazionali,
e quindi aiuta la distribuzione.
Ma in più,
questa missione ci ha permesso
di trovare moltissime tecnologie:
per la prima volta nella storia dell'uomo
abbiamo riparato il DNA,
danneggiato da radiazioni.
La stazione orbitante è un sistema chiuso,
quindi l'acqua è contenuta: perciò -
forse adesso vi darà un po' fastidio
quello che sto per dire -
ma abbiamo dei sistemi
di depurazione dell'urina.
L'urina degli astronauti viene ribevuta,
il sudore degli astronauti viene ribevuto.
Tutte queste tecnologie
possono essere utilizzate sulla Terra
dove l'acqua è carente.
Abbiamo sviluppato delle alghe
che sono altamente nutritive,
forniscono alimenti
dove il cibo è carente sulla Terra,
come ad esempio in Centro Africa
e in Sud America.
Guardate che cosa vuol dire
fare un massaggio cardiaco sulla Stazione.
Come vedete, è una manovra
estremamente complessa:
ecco perché abbiamo trasformato
il defibrillatore che voi trovate ovunque,
e lo abbiamo reso portatile.
Questo vi permette
di trovarlo dappertutto:
non soltanto nei centri sportivi,
ma anche nelle strade, nelle piazze.
Salvavita.
Ma vogliamo fare di più,
vogliamo fare questo.
Vogliamo mettere
il defibrillatore su un drone.
Voi avete un’app nel vostro telefonino,
schiacciate l'app
e il drone arriva dove siete voi.
Ci arriva perché avete un segnale GPS
che vi viene fornito da noi,
quindi ci arriva molto precisamente.
(Applausi)
Quel drone atterra vicino a voi,
parla ai passanti e dice:
"Questa persona non si sente bene,
mettimi sul suo petto, al resto penso io",
E salva la vita.
Vi presento Simon.
Simon è il primo robot
ad intelligenza artificiale.
Lui ha un software
di riconoscimento facciale,
quindi non soltanto
riconosce la faccia dei comandanti,
in questo caso Alexander Gerst,
ma in più ne comprende lo stato d'animo,
quindi gli si rivolge
con modi e toni adeguati
per quel suo particolare stato d'animo.
Ora per una missione a lungo termine,
ad esempio andare su Marte,
questa è una tecnologia fondamentale,
perché ci permette
di alleviare il carico di lavoro,
comprendere le dinamiche dell'equipaggio.
Riportato sulla Terra,
ha molteplici utilizzi,
ad esempio nelle missioni
di esplorazione dei poli:
grande isolamento.
Le navi che restano in mare per sei mesi.
Oppure le persone anziane.
Non sarà mai come
un essere umano, questo è chiaro,
ma è certo meglio di una macchina muta.
La Stazione ci ha permesso, anche,
di cambiare un altro paradigma.
Questo è il futuro dell'aviazione, Skylon.
Skylon ha un motore ibrido:
una parte è un motore commerciale,
quello che è usato sugli aerei di oggi;
e una parte è un motore a razzo.
Skylon arriva ad una certa quota
con il motore commerciale,
accende il razzo, esce,
vola a 28.000 km orari,
vuol dire New York - Sydney in tre ore.
Vuol dire che tutto, diciamo -
l'inquinamento intanto avviene di meno,
perché il viaggio è più corto;
e poi è fuori dall'atmosfera,
quindi non inquiniamo la Terra.
Ma noi vogliamo fare di più,
vogliamo fare questo.
Questo è un cancello
sullo spazio profondo.
È una nuova base,
una nuova Stazione orbitante,
questa volta attorno alla Luna,
non più attorno alla Terra.
Ci costerà dieci volte meno
della Stazione Spaziale:
abbiamo imparato, anche,
ad ottimizzare i nostri processi.
In più ci permetterà di fare diverse cose.
Primo, supportare
le missioni di superficie;
secondo, supportare le missioni
che andranno su Marte -
superficie sulla Luna.
Pensate: astronauti a bordo nel 2024,
prima donna sulla Luna nel 2024.
In più ci permetterà
di realizzare un altro sogno,
che è quello di costruire
una base sulla Luna,
perché è questo quello che vogliamo.
Vogliamo tornare sulla Luna:
questa volta non per esserci,
ma per rimanerci.
La Luna è ricca di platino,
di titanio, c'è elio-3,
che permette di produrre energia nucleare
senza scorie radioattive.
È un'opportunità scientifica unica anche,
perché permette di osservare lo spazio
senza l'aberrazione dell'atmosfera,
quindi possiamo avere radiotelescopi
che non sono filtrati dall'atmosfera
ed è un'opportunità
di testare tutte le tecnologie
che utilizzeremo poi
nel volo ben più complesso,
quello per Marte.
Però la Luna, diciamo, questa nuova sfida,
ci permette anche
di sviluppare tecnologie.
Primo, costruire la base lunare:
non la costruiremo
come se fossimo sulla Terra,
utensili, materiali -
pensate cosa vuol dire costruire
una casa sulla Terra.
Non faremo così. Lanceremo -
E quindi lanciare poi
tutto questo sulla Luna.
Non così.
Cambieremo completamente.
Una stampante 3D,
la polvere che è già sulla Luna
e il Sole come unica forte di energia.
E la base la costruiremo
completamente automaticamente.
Ora riportate questa tecnologia
sulla Terra, che cosa significa?
Significa avere possibilità
di costruire case
dopo terremoti o dopo gli tsunami
in ambienti estremamente difficili.
Ma gli astronauti, poi,
non avranno soltanto bisogno della base.
Avranno bisogno, anche,
di utensili ed equipaggiamenti.
Una parte di questi utensili
verranno lanciati:
altri dovranno essere costruiti lì,
quindi avremo bisogno
di plastica e di metalli.
Qual è la fonte ovvia
di plastica e metallo sulla Luna?
È quella che abbiamo
portato noi, sono i Lander.
I Lander, una volta atterrati,
non servono più.
Quindi cannibalizzeremo
tutta la plastica e tutti i metalli
e li ristamperemo con stampanti 3D
in oggetti utili
per quella fase di missione.
Il riciclo dovrà essere fondamentale
sulla Terra se vogliamo preservarla.
Questo è il cratere Shackleton,
a sud della luna.
Quello che vedete in rosso è acqua.
Acqua vuol dire vita,
vuole dire acqua da bere,
vuol dire ossigeno e idrogeno.
Ossigeno da respirare,
ossigeno e idrogeno come combustibili
per mantenere la base.
Però quell'acqua è:
prima di tutto ghiacciata,
e secondo è mischiata a terriccio.
Vuol dire che dobbiamo avere
delle tecnologie per estrarre l'acqua.
Queste stesse tecnologie
saranno utilissime per quel bambino.
Tutto questo lo stiamo già testando.
Lo stiamo testando qui,
nel ghiacciaio di Zermatt.
Undici università europee,
tra le quali il Politecnico,
stanno testando tutte queste tecnologie
in un ambiente rappresentativo della Luna.
In più abbiamo la robotica.
Il nostro comandante Luca Parmitano
controllerà questo robot dalla stazione
come se fosse sulla Luna.
Quindi tele-robotica:
sulla Terra, significa telemedicina.
Vuol dire che un chirurgo a New York
può operare un paziente a Milano.
In più,
questo braccio robotico è alla base
della microchirurgia sulla Terra.
Ma vogliamo fare di più,
vogliamo andare su Marte.
Astronauti su Marte
entro la fine del 2030,
e per farlo avremo bisogno di questo.
Marte è a due anni di distanza da noi.
Per motivi di astrodinamica,
noi non possiamo interrompere la missione,
quindi dobbiamo fare tutto il giro.
Vuol dire che dobbiamo
poter riparare gli astronauti.
Prima pelle, primo osso umano
stampati 3D con cellule staminali.
Organi umani,
vuol dire possibilità di trapianti
senza bisogno di aspettare un donatore,
vuol dire testare le medicine
direttamente sull'organo
che si vuole curare,
senza far del male
agli esseri umani o agli animali.
Ma perché andare su Marte?
Il motivo è questo:
la Terra mantiene le proprie dimensioni
e noi continuiamo a crescere,
quindi abbiamo un problema di spazi,
abbiamo un problema di risorse,
abbiamo un problema di inquinamento,
quindi andiamo su Marte
per avere altri spazi, nuove risorse,
ma non vi preoccupate:
non andiamo su Marte perché pensiamo
che la Terra sia spacciata,
e quindi andiamo da un'altra parte.
No, tutt'altro.
Noi andiamo su Marte per questo motivo.
Marte era una Terra.
Non sappiamo per quale motivo
poi si è trasformato
nel deserto ghiacciato che è oggi,
con effetto serra
completamente fuori controllo.
Quindi noi andiamo su Marte
per capire che cosa è successo lì
e per evitare che succeda da noi.
In più andiamo su Marte
con rispetto e in pace.
Abbiamo un ufficio
che si chiama Planetary Protection
che ci eviterà di fare gli stessi errori
che abbiamo fatto sulla Terra.
Stiamo diventando
una specie multi-planetaria,
vuol dire che abbiamo l'opportunità,
per la prima volta,
di portare la nostra vita,
i nostri ideali, la nostra cultura,
su un altro pianeta.
Per far questo, però,
abbiamo bisogno di tutti voi,
e non saranno solo ingegneri come me.
Avremo bisogno di biologi,
di medici, di psicologi, di filosofi.
Tutto questo avviene adesso.
Lo spazio è ispirazione,
quindi noi attiriamo le menti migliori,
le confrontiamo con sfide di questo tipo,
e produciamo tecnologie e scienza
a protezione della nostra Terra
e della nostra vita su di essa.
Ah, dimenticavo.
Tutto questo vi costa
come il biglietto di un cinema all'anno.
Ora, io ho la mia risposta
per questa domanda,
ed è la risposta
che ispira tutta la mia vita
e dà un senso alla mia esistenza,
perché penso di fare qualcosa
per quel bambino, qualcosa di concreto.
Lascio naturalmente a voi
la libertà di rispondere.
Grazie.
(Applausi)